donc vous connaissez mon histoire
j'ai encouragé monfils à s'enrôler
c'était la tradition famille
comme moi comme mon père
avant moi six mois plus tard il mourait
auniac mon pays sauvés à quoi à quoi
ressemblera le monde en 2050 période
très difficile va commencer les maladies
opportunistes l'anarchie et la loi
martiale
vous verrez ça dans votre vie du petit
minou parthenay pour ce que nous avons
fait à sa création je pense que vous
devriez prendre du recul réel revêtez
vous de toutes les armes de dieu
c'est de l'avenir de ce bon qu'on est en
train de parler il faut bien que
quelqu'un fasse quelque chose pour nous
c'est comme si j'avais peur de tout
[Musique]
oh
et c'est tout ça faisait partie de son
plan et qu'on n'était pas en mesure de
le voir
car nous n'avons pas à lutter contre la
chair et le sang mais contre les princes
de ce monde de ténèbres
[Musique]
ces mots